a new Game of Thrones teaser trailer is
out now what does it reveal about the
final season of Thrones we see the
painted table on Dragonstone a big map
of Westeros
there's a direwolf representing the
Starks dragon for the Targaryen and a
lion for the Lannisters these are the
three main houses left in season eight
last season's teaser showed a more
complex political situation with houses
Baratheon Tyrell and Greyjoy entangled
with the others but now the Baratheon's
Tyrells and Martel's
are all dead and the politics of Game of
Thrones is simpler than it's ever been
the final season is less about politics
and more about ice and fire an icy fog
sweeps across Westeros symbolizing the
White Walkers and their army of the Dead
it covers the north freezing the stark
direwolf
maybe hinting that Winterfell will fall
to the walkers the Targaryen dragons
freezes like how Daenerys dragons
Viserion is now controlled by the night
king in the south the Lannister lion
burns which might hint at the deaths of
Cersei and Jaime some speculate that
Cersei will die in a fire that just like
she blew up that Sept she might burn
down the whole city of King's Landing
and in the books the Lannister twins
believe that they will die together in
the middle of Westeros Ice and Fire
clash representing a battle between the
living and the dead this happens on the
map near the river Trident just as
Daenerys dreams of a battle in book
three but if the Walkers get that far
south they could have millions of dead
northerners in their army this war for
the dawn will be on an apocalyptic scale
amidst the Ice and Fire this black
crystal stuff appears which might
represent dragonglass
the obsidian that kills White Walkers
and the dragon glass seems to take the
shape of like a wall across Westeros in
season 7 there's a book that says that
dragon fire can be used to reshape
dragon glass to build things
so maybe Daenerys and her dragons will
shape dragon
to build a wall and make the walkers pay
for it oh maybe this is just a cool
visual effect either way this represents
a truly epic battle the Song of Ice and
Fire that the book series is named for
but is this really how Game of Thrones
will end after seven seasons of human
drama and intricate politics will the
end be a fantasy battle where the good
guys beetle the bad guys the series
creators have said it'll be more complex
than that and there is some dark strange
stuff in the prophecies and lore of
Thrones like legend says that last time
the White Walkers attacked they were
defeated by a hero who sacrificed his
beloved wife so maybe John will kill
Daenerys and there are hints of
cooperation and even marriage between
humans and White Walkers
maybe Westeros will make a deal with the
Walkers maybe Jon will become the new
night king maybe that's what the frozen
direwolf means there are lots of
possibilities so the final season of
Thrones won't have time for much
politics or minor characters or travel
times making sense it'll be more Fire
and Ice and CGI but there are still big
shocks and revelations to come mysteries
will be uncovered prophecies will be
fulfilled claw gains will Bowl and
characters we love will die because the
story has nothing to lose now this is
what it's been building up to there are
just six episodes left we'll be covering
lots of Game of Thrones content from now
to the finale so check out our videos
and subscribe and click the bell during
season eight we'll do a video for each
episode as well as weekly live streams
for patrons if you want to support alt
shift X and get extra updates live
streams and behind the scenes stuff sign
up at the patreon link below this
artwork is by attached LT knows he's
gotten heaps of great speculative
Thrones art so go check him out thanks
to patrons Tracey Wynans Dylan J Roebuck
Zachary Bain Abhishek rau Anthony Mackie
dobro Deep lured and Mellie
of Cheers
you